foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I guess I should lower the excitement
level hey there kids
because this is a very special edition
of uh fat man beyond colon the stroke
writer strike
uh welcome to fat man beyond special
edition on the strike I'm Kevin Smith I
am Mark Bernardin hey ho this is our
news voices
um Mark had an idea about uh joining up
uh
uh and talking about uh strike which is
good because I'm completely
ignorant myself
um
for those who don't know well first off
for those who are like what the
happened to your
place because the strike I had to sell
everything so we're not millionaires
yeah that's it if I can't write I got no
money so I sold everything behind me no
uh we are in the process of packing up
and and moving uh from my house not
anytime soon but uh
well I I guess within the next two
months or something but uh my office was
one of the last to get packed up and so
look at this look how Barren is
you know and having been in your house
on more than one occasion it's a lot of
to pack oh my God I mean I'm a
hoarder kids an absolute hoarder
so all the stuff that used to line these
shelves
uh got hacked and sent into uh some
things are in storage out here in Los
Angeles some some things went into those
pods that you see sometimes like are
outside people's houses and
excuse me um and got shipped back East
uh to smod Castle where I have a
small apartment above the theater which
won't hold all the we
shipped out so
that one of the storage my life's in
storage right now
um but you know I live out of a suitcase
and uh
that's that's good because the belts are
tightening kids we're living in some
Frugal times right now man because those
of us who make our earning off of words
who turn words into Dollars uh aren't
doing that right now are we Mark we are
not uh as of last Monday I want to say
it was the fourth maybe I don't know how
calendars work anymore
um uh it was no it was the first uh both
the writer's Guild uh East writer's
Guild of America East and The Writers
Guild of America West
um elected to uh strike and I'm sure
some folks have heard that
uh read about it online or seen you know
people's Twitter threads or Instagram
threads
um regarding the strike uh particularly
Marx Mark's been walking the picket line
and stuff something I have not had a
chance to do because I've been out
dealing with my mom who is getting
better outstanding yes she had a they
took the tube out of her nose the
feeding tubes she could feed herself now
and she had a tracheostomy she had the
tube in the throat they took that out
today so she's like tube free
um so
thanks mod
um but you you might have seen
little bits and pieces about the strike
and and been like what's this all about
what do you mean strike well that's what
we're here to talk about today in this
very special edition
of fat man beyond uh mark
is our resident strike expert
um having the two of us
certainly between the two of us Mark is
Norma Ray so we're gonna learn
all about what's going on uh with the
writers and why we're striking mark
and me
what we're striking about
um yeah I mean and the idea for this
basically came down to we were going to
talk about as we always do
um two there's two there's three
segments of the show the first one is
what are you up to the second one is
here's the news the news is what I'm up
to
um because there isn't really any other
news aside from the fact that the
Writers Guild of America
um as they can do every three years uh
we have a contract The Writer's Guild
with the amptp which the alliance of
Motion Picture television producers
which is you know the the shorthand for
the studios and the networks the people
who pay us to write
um and then the union that protects the
writers and allows us to collect a
bargain every three years there's a
re-examining of that contract and every
three years
um the writers have some things that
they want and also not just the writers
every Guild in Hollywood the Directors
Guild of America and the Screen Actors
Guild all have the same kind of
agreement with the amptp the studios
every three years that agreement expires
every three years there's a series of
negotiations sometimes people get what
they want and they go back to work
sometimes people don't get what they
want and they go up into the very last
moment and then they negotiate and then
they they compromise and then sometimes
the two-step parties are at such a an
impasse that a strike gets called and
the last time there was a strike was in
the 2007-2008
um television season
um the strike was over the in the winter
who's in the in the fall into the spring
um and not during may not during the
summer but so basically this year
um the writers came to the table with
some very
um serious but fair demands
to existentially retain the ability
specifically to be a TV writer
um as a career one can do and make a
living doing it
um feature screenwriters have often felt
a little bit sidelined by it but there
is also some stuff in there that affects
everybody namely the fact that streaming
seems to have
um greatly diminished if not completely
destroyed the old formula people used to
make money
um especially if you're a writer but
also if you're a director also if you're
an actor because everybody made their
money up front like here's what you paid
me to do this service but then here is
what was called residuals
um if you're an author it's called
royalties
um it's I created this thing and every
time you sell it to somebody else the
originator of that thing gets a taste
and it's a small taste it's not you know
an immense percentage of what the
grosses are but those were sizable if
you if you do them in the aggregate they
were sizable even if you wrote one
episode of TV if you wrote an episode of
Seinfeld
um you got paid to write it and then you
got paid every time it aired in reruns
and syndication all of it if you write
an episode of stranger things you get
paid once and then you never really get
paid again because when did that happen
like essentially the streamers
um kind of broke the old model correct
like when uh streaming came to the fore
uh they considered it New Media is that
correct like they were like we don't
know if this thing's gonna work can you
imagine kids that at one point Netflix
was like we're not sure it's gonna work
yeah I mean that's what the 2007-2008
strike was about it was the the trying
to wrap your heads around what stream
was going to be the the studios claimed
that it was marketing it was a marketing
tool it's like we're not going to put
look at like putting whole episodes of
stuff and then we're gonna put all
seasons of TV up in there we're gonna
give you like a five minute clip of
Heroes and that's all you're gonna get
like we're not we don't even know what
it is but the writer's Guild says well
but at some point you'll figure it out
and at some point that will be
destabilizing so we need to wrap our
heads around it and so what happens was
like yeah the show used to get rerun
show would get so solidification but
once Netflix began creating original
content
they realized that there was no resale
for it they would own it and the only
place it would air was on Netflix and
they were not going to sell ads against
it so they paid you a little bit more up
front and said there are no real
residuals for this and the problem is is
that now there are shows there are
people writing these shows who are not
getting to partake in the success of
those shows
um which had traditionally been the way
TV worked if you created Hill Street
Blues if you created The Sopranos if you
created you know
friends then like you've got a taste of
that success and even if you create even
if you just wrote on a show like Miami
Vice even if you just wrote an episode
of
whatever the hell you know pick a show
that you don't even remember anymore
you still got paid to do it there were
reruns you get paid again for having
written it all of that is gone now and
that has sort of decimated the ability
for writers to sustain themselves
you know like and I used to be I'm going
to go through a list of grievances but
if you were on Quantum Leap in in you
know the 90s or the 80s or whatever you
worked 40 weeks of the Year writing 22
Episodes of Television you took a
10-week Hiatus and you went back to work
again
now if you're writing on
I don't know let's call it Castle Rock
um you're working for 20 weeks out of
the year
um
on 10 episodes that are for a streamer
and the money that you used to get to
sustain yourself through that time you
don't have any more you're working for
less you're trying to get more jobs
there are more writers trying to get
more jobs and it's just becoming
unsupportable ecosystem and
unsupportable economy and so that's one
of the big things that that writers are
asking for in addition to the streamers
telling us how many people are watching
shows like the only way we have any idea
of whether or not something is a hit is
if Netflix puts it in their top ten but
what's number 14 what's number 23 how
can you how can you equitably negotiate
for yourself how can you be humble but
let know how much you're
worth if you don't know how much people
are watching so tell us what what's
happening tell us how many people are
watching and then let's figure out a
residual formula based on a number of
views
um so that again if you create your next
big hit Netflix show then you can have a
taste of that success
um I think that's that's all that
anybody's looking for is it is a taste
not that much A Taste
um I think feature writers also like if
you write the most popular Netflix movie
if you write whatever the hell the gray
man you know if you write whatever is
going to be on Apple if you write Tetris
if you write you know some original
streaming movie
if you used to be if you wrote a movie
that went into theaters you got a piece
of that money that could be that could
be a career for you that could like you
know middle class you're gonna be rich
but you would always get some money for
having written a movie that people love
um that is also now gone because they're
not cutting you in to that sort of
success
um
and then the other big thing you know to
just sort of break it down and it's most
Elemental is also protecting against the
encroachment of artificial intelligence
um
writers are concerned because things
like chat GPT and I'm sure there's other
off-market off-brand versions of that
are not currently being used to write
Scripts
but in a couple years they can mimic
scripts you know like if you if you ask
you know chat GPT hey I would like you
to synthesize 40 Years of police
procedurals and then kick me out of
police procedural
is we're a year or two away from them
being able to do that and then hiring
one writer to rewrite it all so that it
doesn't sound quite so boring as opposed
to Let's hire a room full of people to
create a new thing
you know this it becomes the enemy of
the new and it becomes the enemy of the
writer and the idea that writers are the
only ones who have to worry about that
is I think a little bit short-sighted
because actors are already like if
you're a voice over actor like
you would 100 just get some of that from
a box I mean sure
they're going to be those who will
always work there will be like your
Nolan North's and your Phila Mars and
your you know your Matthew Mercers and
your John Hammes and your George
Clooney's if you've got a recognizable
voice and a brand yeah you're gonna keep
working but if you're just a guy reading
a script for some you know documentary
on World War II they don't need that
person anymore
you can get that out of a box I mean we
get Darth Vader out of a box now because
they've synthesized all of James Earl
Jones's Voice work as Darth Vader and
now you can just type in what you want
him to say and he says it that's how
Kenobi worked that's how Darth Vader
shows up in Kenobi because James is too
old that he's licensed his voice to
lucasfilm that they can now summon Vader
whenever they want to
that's the thing you could do that yes
I'd like to sell my entire Silent Bob
voice catalog I mean and have it
there's lots of shrugs AI shrugs man
um do you get
uh speaking of shrugs lots of shrugs
online
from folks who are like
Hollywood strike you don't even work or
blah blah where have you found a lot of
support
um I found like 90 worth of support
um because I think that that people do
have a rudimentary understanding and the
WJ has done a pretty good job of
communicating
um what their core issues are and the
intransigence of the studios to actually
Faithfully negotiate on those core
issues um so I think most people are are
at the very least vaguely on the side of
the writers
because it's so weird to me to be on the
side of some faceless megabonical
Corporation
um so I guess corporations should win
they should have all the things
um you know and I think they understand
that what the writers are asking for
amounts to two percent of the profits of
the billions that they make on stream
you know there was there was a writer
who explained to me a guy named Paul
guyote who was like
um Netflix has 200 million subscribers
give or take 40 million or so each one
of those subscribers has a credit card
and each month that credit card gets
charged somewhere between 10 15 20 a
month
so that is
however that math Works you're in the
billions that they're making a month on
subscribers and so to to claim that they
just don't have any money
feels somewhat insincere they are not
broke they are not crying poverty
um they have plenty
um they they have done record profits
especially given that we were in a
pandemic when all one could do was watch
at home
um
and so and but then there are some
people who of course are like if you're
just asking for millionaires asking for
more money you know for example the card
Barren in comments said maybe they can
write something worth watching for once
yeah you know there's be like you know
who needs hopefully you stay on track
forever so we can hire some writers who
aren't like left-wing liberal child
grooming pedophiles like oh okay you're
bringing a lot to this table sir I don't
I don't understand where any of that
comes from but sure okay
grievance heard and muted
um but I think that that there is
something somewhat intrinsically
American about
um kind of punching upwards trying to
take down the man and claim a little bit
more of what's yours
um and what you think you owe you're
owed you know value valuing yourself and
then sort of doubling down on it
um nobody wants a strike you know
there's no writer out there who's
excited to not be working
you know I mean I had two or three
things on the runway that were that
showed lots of promise you and I had a
thing on the runway that uh that showed
a ton of promise that we all had to kind
of put on ice and wait until this gets
resolved like this nobody wants to not
be making money
um but I think that that it does come
down to
um if we don't stand now when do we
stand and if standing later is too late
um and so that's sort of the the general
thesis of it it's trying to make sure
that writing for the screen is a career
that people can have that it isn't just
for the wealthy and the elite
and most of the people who write the
television that you love are not rich
not if you're living out in La not if
you're trying to sustain yourself here
you know there's a dude who uh who was
writing on the bear
who you know who like yeah you know an
incredibly popular show on on you know
FX on Hulu
um critically louded you know maybe up
for people of surprises or peabodies or
whatever the hell it was he's like I
don't know where my next rent check is
coming from
like I just don't know how I make the
year I don't know how I make the month
let alone the year he's like I just
delivered my last script for the bear
season two
and so you know and there are lots of us
out there who are just trying to to
Cobble together a year trying to get
jobs trying to score another gig trying
to do a freelance episode writing
animation writing whatever you can write
because it is not the uh the land of
milk and honey that it had been in as
late as the 2000s
um let alone in the 80s where people
were giving away Porsches if you were on
a hit show
um is that right yeah yeah yeah I mean
granted I think it was friends were
giving out Porsches
um it's like hey guys we're number one
everybody gets a car
[Music]
that's great
thanks
um we're not in a lot in that world
anymore you know with very rare
exceptions like sure there are shows
that do well there are people who are
rich they're your Shonda rybins and your
Greg berlantis and you know people with
these giant overall deals at companies
and
yeah they produce they're worth the
money but
most of us are not rich most of us are
you know just trying to make it we're um
of course all of us all we writers as
part of the guild are striking but this
seems to affect uh
episodic folks more than it does feature
folks or am I ignorant
um for the most part you know I mean
future folks there there are always some
protections that the future folks want
namely I think that the biggest thing
that the feature writers are asking for
is to
um be paid more consistently
um because like if you if you write a
movie that sells and it's your first one
ever and you're going to get Guild
minimum you know even a little bit above
going on let's say our friend Scott
Moser
sold the spec script to Warner Brothers
for a movie called mod versus mod mod
video
which they you know instantly turned
into a eight-figure package
for a feature that's gonna star Angelina
Jolie and Holly Berry but he is I mean
he's written episodes of like Spider-Man
and one of the Spider-Man cartoons and
stuff but he's a first time feature
writer he's a first time feature writer
who comes from also having produced and
directed The Grinch
um he's not an unknown quantity you know
he's that that is the anomaly and not
the norm to come in for some like oh
yeah I made 14 million dollars selling
this script as a package or whatever
that is right if you're like a regular
person with no credits in this business
and you sell a movie maybe you get 200
000 for selling that movie Maybe
um thirty percent of that goes away for
taxes another 25 of that goes away for
commissions to your agent manager lawyer
um that leaves you with 45 of that 200
million you know two hundred thousand
dollars
what is that eighty five thousand
dollars ninety thousand dollars and if
you're living out here in Los Angeles
good luck Megan that work
because it's an expensive place to live
and this is an expensive place to live
and you might not sell another one for
another two years right you know and so
you gotta make eighty thousand dollars
last you for 24 months in a town like
this like that's not a rich person you
know that's a person who's like solidly
lower middle class
you know and so finding ways to make it
so that that person can a get a bit more
for that sale not have to wait so long
for that money you know be part of the
process of of being involved and doing
more than one pass on the script like
getting paid to do a rewrite getting
paid to do a third draft getting paid to
do a Polish like all of that can be
money applied to that sale so that you
know ultimately what we're fighting for
is the lower end
of of the career for the people who are
just starting for the people who are you
know just breaking in getting their
second third jobs and making it so they
can get their fourth job and then in
television specifically it's learning
how to do the job you know like I've
I've been on seven TV shows
and I've been on set for one episode
now at some point they will give me a
show to run you know knock on wood I'll
sell a thing and I'll be the show winner
of that show explain for those who are
completely ignorant what a show runner
is
um in television the showrunner is the
the sort of creative
um Source from when from whence it all
Springs they're they're the last line of
defense for the creative and they are
the head of what is ultimately like a
100 million dollar business employing
between 10 and 200 people where you're
helping to cast the show you're helping
to write the show you're making the
final decisions on everything creative
about the show you're on set to produce
the show to make sure that what's
happening while people are are you know
rolling trucks and rolling cameras and
costumes are right and oh man we don't
have sun today and oh it rained out
this set what do we do it's it's problem
solving in a rapid pace
um It television is a is a writer's
medium it's often said and the
showrunner is the director of Television
is the one who is the the first and the
last word on most of what happens and
much of being a showrunner is not just
learning to write but it's learning how
to produce and work with other people
and interface with department heads I
mean it's it's a lot of stuff that that
I learned in theoretical that I learned
a bit on set for the episode of Castle
Rock that I produced that I learned
making my own short you know and that I
learned from watching other share
Runners and other directors do that job
it's uh there's a lot to it and there's
a lot of trust and there's a lot of
confidence that one has to have that
they can do that job
but it used to be that like start as a
staff writer on La law you went to set
you interfaced with you know Jimmy Smits
and and and Blair Underwood and Corbin
Bernson and yeah I remember the cast of
I mean what the what an
ancient poll that is
La law was a show that happened way back
in the 80s and stuff Mark's reaching
very far back reaching very far back
because that's to a certain degree how
long ago it was that you could do this
where you started as a staff writer you
produce your episode you were on set for
your episode you got to go into post and
watch this the episode gets edited you
offer creative input on the editing of
the story because you as the writer are
the only real container of knowledge
about what that story does and what that
story means in the whole of the season
um and then you'd you'd get promoted and
you'd keep doing that and you'd get tens
and twenties and hundreds of hours of
producing television under your belt
before it got to be your turn to be a
sure owner and at that point you were
armed with all of the knowledge base
that you've built over time but I've
been on like I said like seven shows and
been on set once and a lot of that
apprenticeship doesn't happen anymore
because we're writing our our episodes
discreetly like hey we wrote all ten
great thanks everybody
um we'll see you at the premiere and
then they go off to shoot the show in in
Johannesburg or Prague or wherever it is
they're not taking the writers with them
there's one producer one showrunner
who's doing it all himself or herself
and nobody's learning how to do it we're
not passing on that skill set we're not
creating the next wave of people for
whom a studio will feel totally
comfortable handing 200 million dollars
and saying all right go make that show
about dragons it's cool you've got this
um instead of hand it over to chatgpt
and be like make us a show about dragons
yeah it'll be great like now analyze
every other show that's been about
dragons and just do the ones that were
good
does not compute does not dragon show
um hey somebody asked in uh chat Daniel
Cola kolayani says can you two talk
about the process of getting the He-man
uh rather Masters of the Universe
writer's room together and a peek into
the negotiation so we could see what
writers uh up again are up against with
a studio that's a fair question you know
that was a situation where
there was no there was a writer's room
but there was no writer's room am I
correct in that yeah I mean animation is
is different than live action for a
number of different reasons it's it's
um there's a different Guild that
organizes animation writers it's the the
animation Guild is the name of it it's I
would see
um 530 837 I think it is and so
animation tends to work the way TV used
to work a long time ago which is there's
a showrunner head writer
he's got a number or she's got a number
two
um a chief assistant a story editor and
then everybody else is kind of freelance
you know and so for for masters
you know we we would meet a couple times
a week and talk through the story that
that Kevin wanted to tell and figure out
the Beats of that story and then once we
kind of all agree with him once Kevin
was happened once Mattel was happy once
Netflix was happy it's like all right
everybody go write your episodes
um
I can't speak to the to the hiring of
that room as much as you can but that
that was the process as far as I knew it
um there was uh I remember there was a
moment where
we all gathered in my house and talked
about what the season would be but then
there was talk about hey man like why
aren't we getting paid for that
uh that was and this was going back a
few years we just recently worked on
Green Hornet as well another animated
project that I guess doesn't fall under
the same writer's Guild rules yeah like
that was that was overseen by the
writer's Guild of Canada which you know
has a sort of Alliance agreement with
the wga so they were very they're very
specific about like hey no we'll pay you
for the time that you're just generating
on every story something we got paid for
um you know if I remember correctly they
paid into our health insurance and
everything like and it was great and it
was great it was different from the the
Master's room because they I think were
were better positioned to take care of
um the needs of the writers in ways that
made them feel good and made us feel
good
um what uh what and where did where is
the studio or this where do the studios
stand on this they haven't immediately
caved and been like oh my God give the
writers whatever they want
no the studios
um they've started canceling overall
deals like that that's the first move
right this is David Simon who worked on
the wire and yeah like they had the deal
at HBO for ever in the end of
the century yeah and they they killed
his overall deal yeah I mean the first
step is and this is part of their
playbook really is first you suspend
them you say listen we're not going to
pay you while you're on strike but we're
not gonna make you go away then after
like six or eight weeks there's a time
in which they can claim Force Major
fancy French word for saying
um an act that they had no control over
has made it so that you're not rendering
your work services and so now we can
kill this overall Deal completely
and an overall deal is basically like a
down payment on a writer's Talent right
like if I'm giving you know with the
promise that that writer will then
deliver a hit show for them so if I'm
Netflix and I offer Shonda Rhimes an
overall deal it's because oh we're going
to get something like Gray's Anatomy
we're going to get something like
Scandal we're going to get Bridgerton
and that'll be great for us and so for
us to be the people who get that next
thing we will pay you x amount of money
a year
and for somebody like Shauna for
somebody like like you know David E
Kelly for somebody like you know JJ
Abrams or something like Rick berlante
those deals tend to make sense
um
but what this allows them to do is say
you know those four or five billion
dollars we were spending in overall
deals over all the riders that we have
in our in our stable we're just wiping
the Slate clean that is not money we do
not have to pay out every year
um and then
then we'll negotiate it lets them like
reset the deck a little bit
um you know and and again like overall
deals not everybody has them most people
don't
um and the people who do have them those
are among the elites you know and it's
and it's not it's not a dumb business
decision to do that I mean
Universal we used to make um Del Toro
movies
um despite the fact that very few of
them made money
um banking that at some point he would
make shape of water
you know he's like oh here's the one
that hit here's the one that made
hundreds of millions of dollars and won
US Oscars it was worth making you know
whatever Crimson
um I wanted to say tied but I know it's
not Crimson Tide and I don't think it's
Crimson wave
um but it was some like sort of Gothic
horror romance with Tom Hiddleston and
Jessica Chastain that kind of nobody
went to go see some people love nobody
went but it was worth it happened
already it happened already and I've
been about 10 years ago I think oh okay
um
so so overall Deals they get to wipe
those clean
um and I think that that's when the
studios begin to think for Real about
re-engaging with the guild and with
their their requests slash demands they
also wait to see what the other builds
do the Director's Guild I think is up
next in their negotiations and after
that the Screen Actors Guild is up next
yeah they just announced both the DGA
and sag also announced that the end of
their deal with the am at least amptp
uh when it's up I think on June 30th
uh
they've not renewed it yet so that's
that means they're going to go into
negotiations next it could be the summer
of the strike a lot of people like sags
not going to strike DJ's not going to
strike but a lot of people are also
saying writers aren't going to strike
and here we are striking so it could be
that the whole town shuts down for a a
red hot minute man I mean you know whose
time it is right now aside from
reality TV
um
Indie filmmakers truly Indie filmmakers
the Indie filmmakers that you know uh
populate Sundance these days where
they're just offbeat or off-kilter films
with you know very famous names and I'm
talking about now's your chance kids to
make your clerks like if you're been
sitting around going like you know I've
always wanted to make a movie
and you could do so because you're not a
member of the writer's Guild or the
DGA or sag or anything like that
they're going to be looking for Content
pretty damn soon because you know the
longer the strike goes on the less is
actually getting made and produced
sooner or later they're going to need
product man so if I'm if I was any one
of ucats who've never done it before
that's what I'd be pursuing right now
making that inexpensive you know no
budget movie I've always dreamed about
in the back of my mind because this is a
there's a window here of opportunity
um where soon every studio and streamer
is going to need content now it also
seems like the streamers
are going overseas for content is that
correct as well I mean Netflix has
absolutely big under Netflix was the
first really Global one
um but when squid gain hit in ways that
nobody expected squid game to hit they
were like hey you know what turns out
Korea's got a lot of television it's
like when when rrr blew up you know last
summer
um it was oh you know what it turns out
that India in various parts of India are
massive producers of movies and
television
um maybe it turns out we should begin
importing some of that stuff here as
well
um you know and I think that there are
networks like you know Brit box or
whatever that have been delivering or or
aggregating British TV there's 50 years
of British TV that most Americans have
never seen
um so I think I think you know they're
going to their deep bench you know they
have a library of stuff they have you
know the ability to to sort of access
International Productions
um you know so I think that for the for
the guilds it's a matter of finding ways
to put pressure hold on a lot of people
in check on wouldn't that make Indie
filmmakers scabs not at all you're
allowed to work for yourself yeah you
know like that then the guild has been
very clear because we got a whole list
of strike rules things you could and
could not do but you can write for your
yourself I can write a movie tomorrow I
can shoot a short tomorrow
I can't do it via any particular Union
and I definitely can't get paid to do so
by any company that we're currently
striking against but you're allowed to
be an entrepreneur 100
um especially if you're nowhere near
this business yeah if you're just a
person in the world there was a time I
was not a member of the of the writer's
Guild
um you know I was a complete Outsider so
no this isn't a nobody's saying like
cross the picket lines be a scab but if
you're an indie filmmaker or a no budget
filmmaker Now's the Time to be making a
thing because sooner or later they're
going to be looking for content and that
is definitely not being a scab I'm so
glad I watch chat because otherwise
get off the show and be like we
did a good thing today and a bunch of
people would be like says stab
like you're a scam if you cross the
picket line to go into your studio and
write and or and write something write
anything for anybody and have them pay
you
um I mean technically I'm not even
supposed to be on the studio property
um you know which is fine like I I have
no reason to be on the Paramount lot you
know I have no I have no business in
there at the moment
um you know and and striking picketing
right now it's awesome you know right
now it's like you know I was explaining
to JC before we hopped on it's like
um that first day in in school after
summer vacation
when it becomes like oh hey man have you
been I haven't seen you in forever did
you have a good summer it's a bit like
reuniony
um
you know when the spirits are high and
people are chanting and singing and you
know famous people are delivering donuts
and pizza and like it's a bit of a party
um and so it's it's nice I mean and I'm
getting my steps in I'm you know I'm
walking like four or five miles a day my
doctor's very happy with me being on
strike
um it'll change
getting your steps in are you getting my
steps in it's like it's like hiking a
very flat runion for you know three
hours a day yeah it's a very flat
running
um that'll change once we go deeper into
the strike once I mean the the last
strike was 100 days it was you know
whatever that is three and a half months
um you know and once we're doing this in
August in Southern California in the
valley when it's 115 degrees out you
know walking around the Disney lot it
won't be like singing enchanting in drum
circles and donuts
it'll be you know the 10 Death March
um but I think the guild is resolved and
I think that you know if the other if
the other unions
um see the existential threats that are
facing their members as well
um then I think it could we could all
come to an equitable resolution that
gives everybody what they need not just
now but protects us for tomorrow
um because to imagine that directors are
somehow immune from AI seems
short-sighted to me
um you know the example that that I used
the other day on Instagram was like
let's say you wanted to make
um an erotic Thriller you know and
you're like hey man you know who made
greater rapid fillers Alfred Hitchcock
you're like hey you know what we're
Universal we own all of Alfred
Hitchcock's movies yeah you know how AI
works we just feed it with data with
examples and then it churns out an
aggregate of all those examples so if I
wanted a movie that looked like it was
directed by Alfred Hitchcock I could
have ai
analyze ingest all of that catalog and
then spit out storyboards
for an Alfred Hitchcock movie create
animatics for nothing to talk movie Hell
put in fake actors for another Hitchcock
movie Hell put in real actors for
nothing to talk movie
like all those things are possible
you know the volume can make for your
backgrounds I mean deep fakes can make
for you actors the the computer can make
for you voices like all of those things
are possible
uh George DeWitt is asking in chat Kevin
Smith aren't you considered management
since you work with the studios to make
your movies so doesn't that mean Mark
can't be on a podcast with you
um well management no I'm a
writer
you know a a showrunner which you are
is in the show am I running well you
were running green on it
but I mean that wasn't a show yet well
it was a room like you know we We Gather
people together and you were we were
doing the services
um for that show even though we haven't
you know it is what it is it is where it
is but you know a showrunner is in the
somewhat unique perspective of
um employing people at the behest of a
studio but he's not an employee of the
studio he's an independent contractor of
the studio
um so that doesn't quite tie him
fiduciarily
um to the Studio's interests
um I I never thought of myself as
management material
um I've always uh you know I'm a rare uh
not rare I'm just a different Beast
altogether
uh in this industry and as much as I
came in from the outside
and I could always go back to the
outside and I spent a lot of plates so
there's always different ways for me to
earn a living
um
you know I can't write I'm a since I'm a
writer's guild member uh but clearly I'm
not gonna cross lines and go
right for any Studio at this point or
any network but uh
to be fair there's not a lot of threat
of that regardless it's not like people
are down my door and going like we
need I ain't Greg
berlante
um but in the in instance of this strike
like I could always go
stand on a stage and
do a live show you know me and Mark and
I do fat man Beyond Live you know it's a
way to
put food on the table as well
um
so yeah I don't know that I've ever
considered myself management or
part of the problem Lord knows if I was
ever like in charge I'd be like pay the
writers everything I've always
considered myself a writer first and
foremost that's all I ever wanted to be
in the business you go back and watch
all my early interviews
like when I first got into the industry
I take myself so seriously as a
writer like you know I've since
lightened up I guess after yoga hosers
it's very hard to take yourself
seriously as a writer because the
audience certainly doesn't
um but I'm that's what got me into this
business was a dream of words long
before I ever thought about making
clerks I wanted to write for Saturday
Night Live Like That was my first
industry Dream well my first industry
dream is I wanted to be Tom savini and
Rick Baker and do special effects makeup
but I'm not a talented artist in
the least in order to do that you gotta
at least draw or be able to
sculpt but I just wanted to play with
fake blood and but my my first real
like concrete kind of boy that's what I
want to do all through high school I
wrote sketches for the talent show and
stuff uh because I wanted to be a writer
for Saturday Night Live and then it
wasn't until I saw Richard link later
slacker uh in 1991 also not a writer's
Guild project you know new dependent
film
that that made sense to me I was like oh
nobody's ever going to come discover me
as a writer and it seemed way too
difficult to get into the business
um you know through traditional means
here was a way to do it where I could
make a movie and be in charge and be my
own director and stuff and and uh you
know it panned out for me on my first
try thank the Lord and then suddenly
people some people not everyone and
certainly no critics uh you know decided
I was a filmmaker or director but you
know
knew if with a gun in my head somebody
was like pick a job I'd be like
writer so I've always identified as a
writer first
um even in my stuff the stuff that I
wind up directing
all begins with the written word
written and directed by Kevin Smith only
once in my career or twice well once
cinematically have I directed something
that I was not the writer on and that
was cop out and boy that worked out
um I've written
sport TV and I've directed for TV when I
haven't necessarily written the script
or haven't written the script at all
every episode of The Flash that I
directed and every episode of Supergirl
that I directed the episodes of The
Goldbergs that I directed I did not
write those
um and it was always weird for me
because I don't value myself as a
director Because unless I'm writing the
script
so first and foremost I've always
thought of myself as a writer and you
know as soon as the writer's Guild
strikes I'm always like
all right let's go because that's if if
I had to pick something to put on My
Grave like what he was in this life
probably be writer you know even even in
podcasting even in something like
you know this where it's kind of uh
we're extemporaneously holding forth on
subjects as we do on fat man beyond my
brain works as a writer you know while
Mark is talking I'm never listening I'm
I'm thinking of something to say next
I'm writing the next thing I'm about to
say except in this uh episode because I
was
really uh Curious I saw how Mark went so
hard for the strike in all of his social
media and you know I was when Mark was
like we should do a show that's all
about the strike I had a I was going to
do something else today I had an
opportunity to do a thing which went
away anyway but um at one point I was
like well I don't want to do that thing
because I'd much rather learn about the
strike with Mark with y'all a lot of
people in the chat who are like I'm
learning a lot
sign me up too I'm actually
learning a lot as well yeah I mean I'm
I'm uh I'm I'm a relatively inactive
guild member in that like I don't go to
meetings I'm I'm part of the writer's
Guild East and I live in Los Angeles so
you know they are you a Writers Guild
Eastman I think writers the least I
think I'm West I mean I started my
career as East
is that wrong not to know are people
gonna call me a scab again I mean
fundamentally there's no real difference
in as much as the guild either East and
West still gives you the same
protections the health benefits are
still great you know although the
pension is still really strong like all
that stuff is kind of across East and
West I just don't get invited to cool
that happens out here because I get
invited to culture that I'm into New
York that I can't go to
um you know because I was living in New
Jersey when I got my first job and they
were like well where do you want to
register and I said well which one is
cheapest because again first job not
making a ton of money and the East was
cheaper
um but like I have friends who are on
the negotiating committee I have friends
who are on the board
um I've been hearing about you know the
the goings on in the advance of every
one of these negotiations for the last
you know seven years eight years well
I've been officially in in the guild and
working and even before them like I was
a journalist for the last strike and so
I remember covering the strike
um and so being in a writer's room while
the guild is starting its negotiations
you just start to hear and you're
talking and and information is kind of
swirling and so when we went on strike
it was you know the the first job is
like walk a picket and then the second
job is spread the word
um and this is the first strike in the
social media era and so I bet that
turned into the way that I thought that
I could contribute is just trying to to
get people to understand what it is
we're looking for
um and how what it is we're looking for
will have zero effect on the average
person
um and we'll have a somewhat negligible
effect on the studios themselves you
know again it's two percent of what
we're looking for
um you know so somebody somebody did the
math of here's the salaries of the CEO
of each one of these companies
and if you add four out of the seven of
them up that's as much as we're asking
for
you know
um which doesn't seem like a ton of
money in the grand scheme of things
um it's a rounding error for a lot of uh
you know companies that this size apple
does not care
um how much they'd have to give up you
know Amazon could care less because
streaming content for those two
companies are negligible at best you
know whatever they make on rings of
power or Ted lasso or Foundation or
Reacher God bless you Jack Reacher
um aren't they they're done
shooting right so they're not Redemption
strike yeah any minute now we'll be able
to watch reach her while the
strike is going on and if if God could
you imagine if we had Reacher on the
strike just walking through the
studio Gates and stopping people
yes
despite the fantasias of Kevin Smith we
don't want that being said we
just happen to like reach her quite a
bit Yeah you haven't seen the kids reach
her is Batman without the cow
Batman meets The Punisher is Batman
without the cow punish you without a gun
yes
um you know and what the strike is
actually getting done this time that it
didn't get done last time is now we have
the support of the teamsters the
teamsters if you don't know boys and
girls are the people who drive the
trucks in Hollywood
um they are the people for whom every
camera that's being delivered onto a
location every costume truck every every
driver of a star everything that moves
on Wheels is controlled by the teamsters
and the teamster the head of the
Teamster Union their boss seems to be
like a down for the cause woman from
Detroit he's got a Jimmy Hoffa tattooed
on her arm and she's like if there's two
people walking a picket line the
teamsters won't cross it like we respect
the union we respect your right to get
what you want and as long as there's two
people on that on that picket line we
will turn the trucks around and they've
shut down filming like Daredevil Born
Again shut down in New York Wonder Man
here shut down in New York I mean in la
um Wonder man's been shut down Wonder
man's been shut down
um even though their scripts are done
even though the scripts are done you
know if you can't roll the truck onto
location if you can't bring the stuff to
where you're shooting if you can't
deliver stuff you can't really shoot and
so being able to turn those trucks
around has actually you know said hey
you know what the Duffer brothers were
like you know we are not going on set
you know we cannot do our jobs on the
final season of of stranger things
because we're writers first
and that's that's how we identify and we
believe in it and being on set to
produce your episode even if you're just
producing in that writing you're still
writing you're still giving you know
alternates for lines you're still
deciding what to cut once you get into
the post post is another chance
editorial is another chance to write the
movie again
um and they're like that's writing it's
all writing and so we're not doing it
sorry Netflix but you're just gonna have
to wait until we resolve this strike for
the next season of of stranger things so
now presumably Netflix gets mad at that
right or are they like we understand I
mean they get mad at it but they're not
going to fire The Duffer Brothers
that's what we're striking for
striking for the Young Writers
the newbies need some protection so we
want to get them those protections
um outreached You The Duffer brothers
are probably way richer than we'll ever
be in this Lifetime right I mean
I I I'd like to think so but also if
stranger things was on ABC
they'd be swimming in money good point
good point this is why you come to the
show kids information like what Mark's
talking about right here your good
excellent point it was a Network show
they would be uh you know
they they who I was trying to think
they'd be David E Kelly for heaven's
sakes it'd be Aaron Spelling like living
in the biggest house in Hollywood
um because they have the biggest hit on
television
um and so like yeah like Tony Gilroy
said that he's you know stepping away
from production on Andor you know I
don't know if they're going to keep
going but it's hard to imagine that you
keep making Andor without the guy who
made Andor
um and then expected to be the Peabody
winning you know Emmy nominated version
of that show
yeah yeah yeah
um but that person needs to be there for
quality control that person needs to be
there to make decisions that person
needs to be there to to help you know
just shoot it on the fly like I had an
idea let's try it this way
sometimes that gives you gold and that's
that's what you're banking on and so
there are some impacts that are
happening you know across streamers and
network shows you know there's some
shows that are being shut down because
they're trying to shoot anyway there are
some shows that are just not writing
like Quinta Brunson was like I'm sorry
we're not making we're not making the
next season of Abbott Elementary until
we resolve this writer strike apropos of
nothing she was a wonderful guest on SNL
last month oh so great there was a there
was an all-time great sketch they did on
that episode of two people in cars like
communicating with each other like
like you suck it was like
instant classic sketch and she was very
funny on that show but yeah so she does
uh what Abbott Elementary yeah which is
ABC's biggest sitcom hit in
a decade since the Goldbergs you know so
and I I've never watched The Goldbergs I
don't know but the Goldbergs did very
well as is AB Elementary they seem to
have won a cycle of like we're hanging a
schedule on this show and right now
they're hanging it on on Abbott
Elementary and their their next season
will be delayed because they're they're
not working for as long as this goes
let's grab some questions from the
audience uh let me see um
oh Banff man's here man everyone give it
up for Banff man he's part of the strike
as well Batman you member of any Guild
uh editors 700 so you're ayatsi right or
the editors that's a separate Guild
isn't it the editor's guild yeah it's
700.
versus it is it is ayatsi though I think
as well I'm part of the Edwards Guild as
well anyway what'd you pop in to say uh
I wanted I had a question then I had
logged a couple questions throughout the
chat my question was
uh part of what
the writers want is transparency and
streaming numbers right how if I've got
the number two show what does that
actually mean
are they keeping that hidden because if
they tell the writers then they have to
share that with the shareholders
and there it gets the SEC involved and
it becomes a much bigger issue than just
keeping it trade secret
um to the best of my knowledge they keep
it secret because they don't want to
tell anybody anything anyway
um you know I think television would not
have willingly shared what any show is
rated unless they needed to tell
advertisers
how much that show is going to be worth
for them I think everybody by Nature
keeps data proprietary
um and I think that's I don't know if it
gets into shareholder business I don't
know if they have to somehow justify
their phony baloney jobs once it becomes
clear that nobody watched floors lava or
whatever
um
but I think it is just a matter of
principle in Tech specifically
um but I think in business at large is
if you just don't tell anybody anything
they don't need to know if we cannot
tell them don't tell them
um and so I think that transparency is
one of the things that unites all of the
guilds in this action which is everybody
wants to know how their shows are doing
so that their managers and agents can
negotiate for them a better deal next
time so that they know oh hey I just did
night agent for you and 300 million
people watched it shouldn't I get a
piece of that action
um as opposed to somebody who created a
show that nobody watched and we're still
somehow getting the same cut like that
just doesn't seem Equitable to anybody
um and so I think it's it's it's prying
from them something they are naturally
predisposed to not sharing
um
so I've got a couple that I pulled
throughout chat uh Anton wanted to know
how do writers survive during a strike
outside of just pulling from their
savings and is there a fund or anything
that people can donate to uh to help
keep food on the table
um I think saving and knowing this was
coming is a big part of it
um I think as Kevin said some of us are
lucky in that we have different revenue
streams which is we can do a podcast
live and we can sell some tickets and
that's money that comes in
um I can write comic books which is a
medium that is not covered by The Guild
and so I could keep doing that I could
you know animation also not covered by
The Writer's Guild so like it's a little
funky
um because you're still dealing with the
studios that are currently struck
um from the live action side to then
have to deal with them on the animation
side but it's doable video games not
covered
um so I could write video games so let's
watch Jenkins and chat suggests how long
until the writers have to start on only
fans and then somebody else said call it
only pens can we do a can we do that can
we like write
is there an equivalent to showing nipple
for writers I mean I'm sure there are
some writers who I you know some might
want to see naked
um but if you wanted to just like what
is that sub stack thing do people make
money off of that I think they did at
one point some might still do the sort
of newsletter
um kind of subscription model same thing
with patreon like sure drop a coin in
the bucket every month and you know you
get access to these 19 blog posts that I
wrote about whatever my love for
Camembert cheese or we could or we could
move to Super Chat on this
episode
Quan right there JC get ready to
Super Chat that
um there there is a an entertainment
um support fund
um that currently exists I don't know if
that's the name of it I I can find out
what it is and and put it up on my
socials but there is a fund that people
can donate to but I think it
specifically is for like lower level
staffers assistance
um that kind of thing those folks have
no protection at all like they they were
always making an hourly wage they were
always kind of scraping by a living four
people to an apartment you know they
were always hoping for the next gig and
the lunch that you would get while
working that gig so they wouldn't have
to buy one extra meal a day like they
were already clawing and hanging on by a
thread and so helping to support the
assistance
um and the script coordinators and those
foot while they do it is important The
Writer's Guild does have a sort of
strike fund
which is
um and it's pretty healthily
um it's pretty robust that offers
interest-free loans
um to writers who might need it
um in case you can't make a mortgage
payment or in case you've got a you know
tuition due or whatever it is you have
to repay the loan but they're not going
to hit you for interest and I don't
think there's an actual term enforcement
to it either
um as but otherwise like people have
asked me like how can I support you on
your strike right now it's just spread
the word you know you know help be an
evangelist for this or drop off pizza
and donuts at the strike lines you know
like if if you if you see it if you see
a person wearing a blue shirt like this
out there in the world I got my strike
shirt on because I just came from the
picket line you know give them a honk of
support you know if you if you happen to
run a business in town either New York
or LA and you see a person wearing a
shirt coming from a picket line or you
see the picket line happening nearby and
I bring somebody some cold war you know
like bring a pizza Bring It Whatever
honk a horn shake a hand
you know especially like there are folks
who were out there like five o'clock in
the morning you know striking Lots
um picketing just to make sure that
trucks don't roll like there there was
two people in New York who were just at
like four o'clock in the morning like
picketing the billion set like kind of
by themselves and I was like that's
that's thankless work that nobody really
gets to see
um and all that stuff support for that
really matters a lot nobody's looking
for a boycott yet nobody's asking people
to drop subscriptions yet so like if you
want to prune your bouquet of of
streaming subscriptions by all means but
you know the guild isn't asking for
anybody to do that yet so I can't do
that either the uh what you get out of
writer strike kids as well uh are very
clever picket signs all up and down I
mean if you follow people on social
media who are involved with the strike
or even nearby taking pictures of the
strike you see a lot of great strike
signs the best one I saw was um uh Zach
Knutson who played the sexy stud of
Kinky Kelly in the sexy stud and
Clarkson he's also a director himself
um he he put up a picture of a writer
that and held a sign that said
chat GPT has no childhood trauma
which means that like you can't you know
no computer is gonna sit there
and be like oh my God uh my
parents were hell and that's why I could
write you a moving scene that an
audience can connect with
um going back to the thing you were
talking about about streaming numbers
wouldn't it be
fair to say
um that when David zoslov over at HBO
Max started killing shows and
pulling like you know they had a Seth
Rogen movie for HBO Max I think it was
called the pickle or something like that
and then they pulled that out of
rotation
and the idea behind that
the unspoken and maybe correct me if I'm
wrong the unspoken idea behind that is
if we leave this here we have to pay
people who worked on it
um and it's not pulling enough numbers
for us to give a
is the correct read of that or am I
wrong
um yeah like residuals and again like
they're they're the residual formula is
different for everything
um especially for movies that might have
been made for originally for theatrical
that then ended up going streaming
especially for like older that was
made before streaming contracts existed
so like Sesame Street why are we pulling
100 episodes of Sesame Street down why
are they pulling 100 episodes of Sesame
Street because they don't want to pay
the people who worked on the old
episodes because that is all part of an
old model that said every time you air
this thing you've got to cut a check to
these 40 different people up and down
the line
um and so I think they ended up saving
money by just listen while it's on here
and now I'm sure they have some kind of
time thing as opposed to for a month we
owe X as opposed to every time we owed
why but either way they're saving money
by pulling down
um Library content especially stuff that
was made prior to streaming contracts
and that's like about the only way you
could figure out not streaming numbers
but what they feel does or does not have
value if they start pulling off
they're like well we ain't earn enough
money off this when the streaming Wars
began and streaming began in Earnest you
know it was this promise of uh We've
turned on a tap that will never
be turned off and you could you know boy
you think YouTube was great we're gonna
put up every episode of every TV show
you ever loved and you're gonna have
access to it forever for 9.99 a
month but then
the unions caught up with streaming like
as we're seeing right now where suddenly
streamers are like well perhaps we
promised too much too soon because
there's a bunch of stuff that sits on a
Netflix or an HBO Max that goes
untouched just because it's there
doesn't mean somebody's always clicking
on it think about how often you go
through uh the the list and pass tile
after tile not everything is
friends where high school kids will
click on it and watch the whole
show in a weekend and stuff like that
some won't ever get touched
just because it's there I mean you know
I used to work in a video store we had
thousands of video titles but
there was a bunch that never got
touched
um same thing with streaming so now in a
world where like is the unions are
catching up with streamers and they're
like well you still got to pay for some
of this they're like well I'm not
paying for something nobody
watches that's ridiculous we're not a
Public Service we're not PBS and
PBS you know uh was the home of Sesame
Street until HBO what bought the entire
Library yeah I think HBO became the sort
of corporate the the overwhelming
corporate sponsor I don't know if the
Heller Rubenstein Foundation still has a
piece I don't know if PBS I'm sure the
PBS Studio still is involved in it but
yeah HBO kind of bought it Lock Stock
and Barrel and so they have Sesame
Street and then it became now we're
counting on the large yes of
Corporations to give us what had been
you know a generational good thing
um and I still I think I mentioned
before I still feel bad that we failed
Sesame Street as a society like guys all
we have to do is buy a tote bag
once a year and we had Sesame Street for
free forever
don't get that super chat ready man I
think it's on I think will Wilkins put
it on uh yeah they did Will Wilkins put
it on
um I will say that when HBO did that PBS
said you and they put all the stuff
that they owned still up on YouTube for
free
so I watch a lot of Elmo on YouTube with
my daughter so there is
PBS is fighting a good fight
always always fighting the good fight
and all they ask is as Mark said you buy
a tote bag just you sons of
uh Ralph Cotto and chat said
will the writers of your I'm not going
to say the sponsor name adds also be on
strike please say yes that's very
humorous but it allows us a Segway oh
nice in the midst of our strike uh chat
kids uh we got to pay some bills here
and stuff uh we got a sponsor this week
uh for this episode even for this
episode we got a sponsor man and it's
the good folks our good friends at
Native ladies and gentlemen uh I love
the feeling of soaking up the sun this
time of year but with all that time in
the sun I am always worried about
protecting my skin you know what I can't
this there's a lie I never think about
my skin ever and I'm always told
you have to wear sunscreen by
people who care about me and and love me
and but I don't but you know I will
now you know why because native makes a
goddamn sunscreen man they can give my
skin the protection it needs and soak up
so I can soak up that much needed Sun
native makes sunscreen can you imagine
this we've been we've been promoting
native since since native was born man
they make this they put on your
armpits they make this they wash
your face with they make this not
hats but that you wash your hair with
but now they make sunscreen is
there anything native doesn't make for
heaven's sakes listen I I right now I am
the person for whom native is
advertising to because I like you don't
traditionally wear sunscreen but I have
been walking a picket line now for the
last week and a half and I've been out
in the sun and I'm beginning to
peel and I'm not loving it but and I
realize this because I'm not wearing
sunscreen because I'm not used
to doing it so now now I need to know
tell me more about this native sunscreen
which I need to wear because I'm tanner
than I need to be careful well let me
tell you about it natives quickly
absorbing ultra sheer hydrating and
lightweight sunscreen formula offers a
broad spectrum SPF 30 protection from
those UVA and UVB rays man all Native
sunscreen is made with a 20 active zinc
oxide formula that is dermatologist
tested and suitable for even the most
sensitive sensitive of skins all Native
sunscreen is made with oils derived from
plants plants not animals plants that
that see because if you've seen
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 you'll
never want to hurt a goddamn animal
again
um plants they derive their oils from
that seal in skin moisture and it's
vegan and cruelty free man don't make a
rocket raccoon for heaven's sakes choose
from one of natives three delicious but
subtle scents for example coconut and
pineapple
or Sweet Peach and nectar doesn't that
sound delicious makes me hungry all for
your face or for your body man or try
natives unscented option let's say
you're one of those people who's like I
don't need fancy smells just
protect my goddamn skin from the UVA and
the UVB well you could get unscented
option as well my favorite would be
pineapple I love the smell of pineapple
I'm a well that sweet peach and nectar
business right there are you really look
at you I eat a peach Mark's getting all
dirty and that's why we got a
strike because that that level
of writing people are like I'm paying
for that sweet peach talking
holy communities writing in Peach
emojis that man loves ass
and nectar
with all Native sunscreen man you get
protection from the Sun that is free of
uh chemical actives oxybenzone
octanoxate and avobenzone which makes
native sunscreen compliant with the
Hawaii act 104 which was passed in an
effort to protect Hawaii's reefs man
they ain't just protecting your skin
they're protecting the goddamn Hawaiian
reefs the the rescue native company
come on give your skin the protection it
deserves with natives mineral sunscreens
go to
nativedeo.com Fatman or use the promo
code Fatman at checkout and you get 20
off your first order that's native
deo.com fat man or use the promo code
Fatman to check out native Deo
dot com slash fat man say it with me
native Deo
.com Fatman or use the promo code Fatman
we thank the good Folks at Native uh for
sponsoring this year's show let's talk
about the strike and whatnot uh they're
they're not crossed they're not scabs
they're trying to make sure you never
get scabs
nice thank you thank you I made a run to
our whole discussion here uh we thank
the good Folks at Native uh and with
that if you want to thank them go to
nativedeo.com Fatman and buy some of
their cool ass man get that
sunscreen Mark hell yeah no I have to
because it's gonna it's gonna get peely
and nobody wants that nobody wants peely
um
Let's uh let's uh let's talk more about
this here strike I see a lot of Super
Chat happening no uh before we jump into
that uh you know you want to see me and
Mark do a show a lot of people are
asking hey man what happened to Fat Man
400 we called this I think uh it's up
here as Batman
399.1 because we don't want to do show
400 online we've been avoiding it
because we want to do it live at scum
and villainy cantina but sooner so
you're going to see a 399.2 399.
so that we can get to 400 officially and
uh do it at this coming villainy Cantina
and there's so much to talk
about uh in as much as Guardians
happened
um the whole world found out I went
crazy and I put up my mental
health video and when I see a lot of
nice people in chat wishing me well and
whatnot also wishing my mom well my mom
has been in the hospital for over a
month and stuff and uh yesterday she got
the tube pulled out of her nose of
feeding tube that she's been on for like
a month and and she had a treat
because she couldn't breathe as well so
they just took the tracheostomy out
today so she's getting steps closer to
getting out of where she is and going to
a rehab facility not because she's
loaded or anything but because she has
to relearn to walk she's been in a
hospital bed for over a month
not moving and stuff so they got to
teach you to walk
um I'm going to see her uh Friday night
I'm going out to Florida and I'm going
to be there of course for Mother's Day
Mother's day is this Sunday kid it is
um here but a lot of people have been
asking about can we see me you can we
see you and Mark sooner or later yes but
I do know of one live show that we've
got coming up or two of them actually I
think it's August 25th which you you
know you're sitting there going what
that's far away get your tickets now
Mark returns to New Jersey to a venue we
both love that I have no ownership in
whatsoever called smodcastle Cinemas yes
it's my movie theater uh in March we did
fat man beyond there and had a blast one
of the best shows we ever did August
25th
we return to Smart Castle Cinemas to do
fat man beyond live again tickets
available right now at
smodcastlecinemas.com and then the next
night I think it is we're doing our
double feature keep calm and Curry on
where we show flu
and then Legend a double feature in
honor of of Tim Curry
um also tickets for that also available
at smodcast tocinemas.com at smog Castle
Cinemas last weekend we did Jay and
Silent Bob Strike Back Jason Muse came
out and it was wonderful and
stuff uh coming up we've got I'm I'm
away for a couple weeks I returned
May 26th is a Friday
we're doing Jaws the movies that made me
series and were showing Jaws nice
um then we're also doing uh the next
night red state if you want to watch Red
State with me and do q a afterwards
um that's happening then May 28th on the
Sunday is Jersey Girl colon the Snyder
cut that's right we're showing the
longest version of Jersey girl ever made
um and that nobody ever saw except one
audience uh the audience at uh
vulgarathon 2005. when we had a bunch of
cats at the Cinerama Dome and we showed
the uncut version of the first time in
18 years that it's going to be seen man
those are the next few events coming up
at smockcastcinemas.com if you don't
mind I will uh fine I'll tell you about
the other ones as well man because we
got a bunch of cool coming up and
people were like I want to support you
during the strike well come to my
goddamn movie theater
strike come to it now no good
strike film exhibitors good God there's
no money in this business whatsoever um
holy Ben Affleck's got a movie
coming out on the 12th two days from now
hypnotic that's right yeah in a movie
directed by Robert Rodriguez also on the
12th book club you know to uh is a
sequel It's not even the first one this
is the second book club book club two I
think the the next chapter I was gonna
say the final answer
book club the next chapter
um what do we got a final Reckoning the
final Reckoning ladies reading books
um Hollywood Babylon returns to Small
Castle Cinemas on June 3rd uh me and
Ralph Garman doing uh uh Hollywood
Babylon there tickets that's
modcastlecinemas.com go buy them right
now we'll wait while you do it uh we
just added last night on July 1st bear
is driving the clerk's cartoon Marathon
because we can show all six episodes of
my ill-fated clerks cartoon that ABC
only aired two episodes of out of
order uh Jeff Anderson Brian
o'holleran going to be there for that
you can come watch take pictures with us
and like that July 2nd is the Blues
Brothers movies that made me The Blues
Brothers you can watch The Blues
Brothers uh with me and I'll Chit Chat
afterwards this is a badass thing man
you ready for this and you might have to
come out for this Mark oh we just added
this July 29th Superman lives we're
doing a script reading of of my Superman
script ah yes the one that they never
made and like that
um that's gonna be a good ass time
tickets for that smart guys
you name it Superman
done done
we'll beat Warner Brothers to the punch
man before they have a black Superman
we'll have a black Superman guy we did
it
um and then of course the aforementioned
fat man beyond on August 25th and uh
keep calm and Curry on on August 26th uh
tickets right now go get some damn
tickets look at all those super chat
questions lighting up never mind Super
Chat go buy tickets for
smartcastlecinemas.com go to the coming
soon page see what's coming and uh
you'll uh you'll definitely see some
stuff that'll make you happy and I have
to imagine that people might be able to
find us in some fashion or regard at
Comic-Con in July
that's right oh we are going to be doing
a show there remember last Comic-Con we
had uh uh uh the Tin Roof Inn we turned
into movies and then we did shows there
all weekend we're doing the exact same
thing this year we haven't officially
announced it yet but you heard it here
first so we'll be doing Hollywood battle
on there we'll be doing fat man beyond
there probably Jane Sal and Bob get old
same lineup that we did last year so
that's going to be jiren Comic-Con let
me ask you this do you think the strike
lasts until Comic-Con do you think the
strike it's May right now will we still
be striking in July
um I I think unless the DGA and and sag
decide to strike as well I think that's
the big pressure point is if everybody
strikes then I think we get this wrapped
up you know like mid-july if not
September
Maybe
wow a summer of the strike Joshua
Munhall who was remember our super
chatter last time we did a show or like
when we did the Super Chat and it
he said remember he was there for when
we did uh the odds of Mark
he came out from uh Texas he said Kevin
I will pay for John borman's Excalibur
to run on June 21st and the cinema can
keep all the money made from tickets and
concessions I just want to see the
greatest film ever made the way it was
meant to be seen let's let's see if we
can accommodate man June 21st
what day of the week is that
June 21st is a Wednesday we're open you
know what Josh I honestly I've been
thinking about that because I remember
he was like so insistent about it and I
asked Ernie I was like can we get
Excalibur and some Warner Brothers title
and Warner Brothers are generally pretty
cool about rep houses and Warner
Brothers at Universal particularly is
very good to work with man
um I might make that happen for you Josh
I mean we it may be me and you alone in
that theater watching the movie but
it you'll see Excalibur the way it
was meant to be seen
and now
um
if you promise young Patrick Stewart
young Liam Neeson and naked Helen Mirren
I think you'll get more than three
people in that house that's true that's
what you get when you see a
Excalibur also you see one of the best
representations of the Arthurian Legend
ever committed to any Medium as far as
I'm concerned way better than Disney's
Sword in the Stone yeah I said it
I'm smelling uh lavender kids keep me
calm because as of yesterday I believe
it was 16 weeks of me being Weed Free
that's right you're dealing with
weed-free Kevin Smith right here and
this is what keeps me going
lavender not this particular brand but
just Lavender in general sometimes I buy
it in a spray bottle like this
yes I'm just calm covered in
lavender and it's Deep Purple
[Music]
um
what else can we talk about in regards
to this year's strike no I don't know do
we need to hit some of these super chats
or are they just people yeah we
need to hit some of these two now now
I'm talking
I'm gonna do super chats but now in a
world where we have no writing writing
salaries the Super Chat is the only way
we're gonna eat so you pick you you pick
the super chats man I'll just say like I
never minded super chats at the end
but it was when super chats were at the
beginning yes all throughout the show it
was super cool oh no oh no we got some
biggies up there man go ahead hit them
super chats all right let's hit those 99
ones first all right Josh mundle yeah to
Mark and Kevin two writers I admire and
appreciate stay inspired to inspire
question it seems for the last couple of
strikes as usuals are the target how to
get rid of them and do a single one-time
payment like they used to do for jokes
so it's a fair price that's what it is
now
what it is is they pay you a little bit
more up front
um for writing a script in exchange for
you not really getting residuals at the
end
um which seems like it would work fine
except that it's
it does not allow you to share in the
success of the show it just allows you
to mortgage that for a little bit more
upfront and like sure most shows are not
massive hits but we also don't know what
a massive hit on Netflix looks like
um so it's really hard to say what a
fair price would be without knowing
exactly how many people are watching
anything
um
so I think it all begins with with with
revealing the data with telling us the
viewership with being transparent about
how shows are are performing then maybe
there might be a fair price potentially
um but that's a fair price it would also
have to change
every year if it's going to go from
being you know stranger things in season
one to stranger things in season five
um because what a fair price was at the
beginning is not a fair price at the end
which is why residual there's already a
formula there for that so I think that's
it Josh I think it's finding ways to be
equitable
Josh we're going to do that Excalibur
screening man you watch June 21st anyone
want to come see Excalibur it's my
castle Cinemas
come on out June 21st man
um we're gonna make that happen
just for you
um but I also like that movie that's why
I'm happy to make it happen
um
iron oxide did not pay to say this but
he said Kevin Smith is irrelevant
meanwhile he's here on my show
okay sweet irony
iron oxide entertainment
um didn't you know that I went
to a mental health facility what are you
trying to trigger me and send me back
laughs
son of a
get back in and God damn it
did a ghost walk over his grave no it's
crazy I'm crazy I'll come for you iron
oxide son of a
if you have more questions I love when
people say on online I've been dealing
with the
honestly since I've jumped online you
know I've been a creature of the
internet I said as I said in my mental
health video uh for the last uh well
since 1995 is when we put
you askew.com up online and ever since
1995 Mark somebody has taken the time on
my Forum to tell me I'm irrelevant and
never understood the irony of that
if you're here iron oxide I'm relevant
if I wasn't relevant you wouldn't
be here
so you've exposed yourself as a fan and
I love you for it
I love how much you love me and I love
you right back
answer another question
uh uh let's see where else we're going
here everyone's like he just wanted your
attention you got it
um let's see well okay this is a lesser
question more just a a statement a
Clarion call
um from Jeremiah Maxwell for the writers
long live the writers oh very nice man
you somebody gonna oh
Frank Herbert yeah residual for that did
you see the trailer for Dune two I did
did you see Austin Butler yoga hoser
star Austin Butler as a bald fade
beautiful fade oh that makes sense man
because Dave Batista was also a member
of uh the harkonens and he's all bald as
and so is what's as Stone yeah
Stalin as uh as the uh Baron component
so I guess it follows that fade would be
bald as well you read the books did it
ever say like fade was bald as a baby's
ass
Nicole
I'd have to go back and check the text
but that's also a choice but sure
sexy sexy bald fade
um but yes he just wanted from a viewers
use from A View Askew soldier in Alaska
the Super Chat is sponsored by manscaped
love you Kevin and Mark can't wait for
the cruise that's right the cruise oh
yeah is anybody coming on the cruise
well I know a lot of people are coming
on the cruise that's how relevant I am
uh we're at 70 sold we're 10 months out
from the Cruise man the cruise
is uh Jay and Saul and Bob's Cruise
Askew man we set sail from Miami and go
to the Bahamas
uh and then we come back three-day
cruise a three-day cruise and it worked
out so well for Gilligan and so uh
who's gonna be on that cruise any view
Askew you could shake a
stick at man you got Dante you got
Randall meaning Brian o'haller and Jeff
Anderson Trevor Fuhrman who played Elias
Jay who played Jay Jason Muse me
um uh there's somebody else got at it a
very prominent figure from Mallrats they
haven't announced yet but he's coming
um and is it just movie people no
man it's also podcast Pals man so me and
Mark are going to be doing fat man
beyond on the boat are you doing other
things Beyond just fat man beyond I
think so I think I'm doing like a
writer's Workshop maybe
um
that which will probably end up being
the black man beyond because they're
like do a black man band I'm like but
I'm gonna have dinner fat man with the
dude like he's right there this is weird
like ignore him and do it without him I
love behind the curtain guys we have so
many activities and there's
gonna when all said and done there'll be
three thousand people on the boat it's
all us it's not like oh we're sharing
the boat with other people so but they
don't have a 3 000 seat Auditorium so
it's not like you can go to every
show so some shows will be
scheduled against one another and stuff
so if you miss fat man beyond you get a
chance to see Mark at black man beyond
yeah or at dinner
you know because he's a filthy
gambling come on come on hit me hit me
you'll find Mark by the all-you-can-eat
shrimp bar every night do you
eat seafood I do eat seafood I remember
going to uh having this conversation in
New Orleans because you were just like
kind of miserable it's like how could
you be miserable look at all this food
is like I don't eat seafood man
oh
I mean I see food and I eat it but not
Seafood uh so yeah you get tickets at
Jay and Silent Bob's
cruisesq.com uh if you want to join us
on that cruise 70 sold a relevant 70
sold uh 10 months nine months maybe now
before we even set sail I honestly
didn't think we'd set sail with even 50
like yeah I was like I don't know who
the wants to go to see with us you
could see me everywhere you could see me
at smodcast Castle on the land
but as it turns out Mark people like to
vacate that's something I've never
understood one of the reasons I went
crazy because I I don't vacate I'm I
work constantly
um because most of my adult life all of
my validation has come from
external forces other people not myself
so
um you know whenever somebody was like
why don't you take a vacation I was like
I do I went here and they're like yeah
but you did a show I'm like well why
would I ever do a thing without doing a
thing um but other people don't have the
same problem other people actually like
going to a place man my brother
I told my brother I was like I can't
believe this many people bought this
cruise this far out my brother's like
how many days is it I said three and
he's like that's why because he lives
down in Florida and he goes on
cruises himself he's like a three-day
cruise is a wicked way to get away and
then you're offering like so much
entertainment so they could do that as
well so it's not just a vacation where
people get to go to a cool place
but while they're on the boat they're
hanging out with you they're watching
shows he's like I completely understand
it so yes Jay and Silent Bob Cruz excuse
see me there see Mark there
see so many people Ralph Garmin uh we'll
be doing Hollywood Babylon Andy mcelfish
will be doing education Jason Muse will
be doing Jay and Silent Bob good old
Jennifer schwalbach will be doing plus
one the list never ends that's
right we got a girl on the boat
but I'm married to her so hands off
we got one we got one one
we got one
um
God hit another Super chatter uh let's
see
yeah that's the same one and that's the
same one out of super chats is that
right I see one from beard McFly for two
bucks oh yeah there it is but hey Kev
what happened to your pops uh behind you
uh if you missed before we started the
show kids
um since the writers went on strike and
I'm a writer I had to sell
everything in order to live to get some
fuel for my fireplace
in May
um I I didn't we're just moving and uh
so the office the museum if you will has
been uh broken down all the that
used to be behind me I'll do this again
that shit's gone
that shit's gone everything's
gone and stuff I I put these few things
up there so it wasn't so Stark and
horrible
everything I own is packed up in boxes
some of which is out here in storage in
Los Angeles uh others of which uh are
we're in two pods that went cross
country to to New Jersey so when I get
back to New Jersey
uh May 26th
for um Jaws and then Red State and then
Jersey Girl the Snyder cut on May 26 27
28th I'm also going to get to unpack the
pot well I think the pods will be
unpacked by that point but I get to go
into the storage and play with all my
before we have screenings before
every screening at uh I think we did it
before we did uh Beyond we do an auction
where it's like I auction off or sell
one-of-a-kind things like that you know
been sitting in my closet forever or
props or anything like that like
it's and we do it because we
make no money as film exhibitors man
like uh
I tell them every time when I do the
auction uh Avatar 2 the biggest
movie of the last year
um we had on opening night Friday night
seven o'clock 12 people
um the uh uh breed three also one of the
biggest movies of this year six people
on opening that Friday nights are
terrible for us at smart Castle
Cinemas
um Shazam at all
um uh Evil Dead Rises which did very
well the movie is doing 50 60 million of
the box office our opening Friday night
had one person in it and
but you know who I love you know I'll
eternally be grateful for that sweet
little Italian man Super Mario
oh my God that movie keeps making money
for the theater it's crazy man
we're I've I've come to accept
the fact that we are a view Askew rep
house Cinema because anytime we do a
thing we did chasing AMU Jason Lee Mall
Rats with Jason Lee and Jeremy London
both sold the out Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back with me and Jay sold the
out Jane sound Bob reboot on 420
had like 150 people at it and that was
on like a Thursday or something
like that so when I show my old
like we're showing clerks uh the car
Bears driving the clerk's cartoon
Marathon uh is coming up in in June I
fully expect that will be sold out
because we got Brian o'holleran and Jeff
Anderson coming in for that so those
movies do very well I bought a movie
theater so I could show my old movies I
guess
um but kids movies do insanely well at
smog Castle Cinemas in Atlantic
Highlands New Jersey go for tickets at
smartcastlecinemas.com
um kids movies do very very well for us
um so in any event
we do auctions before each screening and
uh the one we did before Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back was astounding
um and that helps us pay our
staff and keep the lights on because we
just got an electric bill like they
Ernie was like we just got the biggest
electric bill I was like why did we use
a lot of electricity this month and he
said no they found out that they hadn't
read our meter or turned it like
looked at it since we took over so it
was an electric bill that went back six
months man it was like almost 7 000
dollars and so
you know the auction we had really
helped us pay that off because I'll tell
you right now brand new movies
ain't packing them in like you know are
you there God it's me Margaret
there was a night where that had three
people
um there was one night where we were
doing uh we did a program recently
called revenge of the Smith where I
showed we did it on May uh on May 5th
revenge of the fifth and uh it was me
pulling all the Star Wars clips from
every movie that I ever made you know I
referenced Star Wars a lot and it was
only 41 minutes of content so I was like
oh this show is going to be fast four
hour show
how do I turn 41 minutes in four hours I
have no idea because I get up after each
clip and tell stories about how it
happened why it happened and stuff like
that so there's a lockdown memory lane
and stuff so
um all the that used to be behind
me like all those one-of-a-kind
pops will be auctioning off at smodcast
of Cinemas before shows to keep the
lights on and stuff so when you come see
a movie it's podcast or at least one of
those movies that I'm involved of it's
presentation that I'm doing you come
make sure you it's gonna be a late night
man because the like the pre-show
auction before Jay and Silent Bob Strike
Back was 90 minutes before we even
started the movie there was a guy in the
audience who was like are we ever going
to watch a movie I was like oh
yeah just you wait yeah just as soon as
we make all the money we need
speaking of all the money we need I see
a lot of super chats up there go through
and pick a pick them out all right uh
Jared Dugas just asked uh Hey guys
wanted to ask if y'all were gonna do any
more Batman movie commentary
I love and appreciate the ones y'all
have done and apologies if y'all have
done some more and they just aren't on
YouTube
how do we get the money for that like if
a bunch of people put up super chat
questions do they just pay when they put
it up where do they pay when we answer
the question uh I I think just will is
taking all of the money and just
buying barbecue or some I mean
we'll put up some money himself to ask a
question which we can get to next anyway
let's answer that question will we do
another Batman commentary yeah
because we can't write anymore
so Now's the Time that would be the
absolute time to do that
commentary track
um which one do we owe which ones do we
owe we stopped with Batman Begins
so we owe Dark Knight
I'll watch that movie I honestly
I'll have no commentary during it
because I'm just gonna be like this
yeah I'll just be mouth breathing the
whole time that was cool that
was cool yeah wasn't that great oh my
God that was so great
um and then we'll do the Dark Knight
Rises yep and then we owe uh the Batman
oh no I'm not doing the other ones
I don't know if I can do that man can I
skip those I don't know if I could do
the Batman it's so it's I mean
I guess you know I guess there'd be a
lot to say you know what actually that
would be one of the better ones
um people love the Batman Beyond
commentary tracks that we've done
um I I see people constantly on my
Twitter feed and uh you know um whenever
we do this people pop up they're like
when are you gonna do that again we will
do this
uh do another Super Chat get get
Wills man get his money we're let's see
where Wells is
um
I don't know how to do it
um I'm just I'm just will net heads uh
will uh you know does a show called net
heads which you could support if you
like good old will Wilkins
um he's not Banff man what name did we
give him he's a dilf man right gilf man
dilf he would pop up and say Jill uh net
heads will says support the writers and
while you're at it subscribe to net
heads here on YouTube there you go he
used it to make his own goddamn
commercial very smart
very wise
um Drew Tannenbaum for 9.99
asks cannot wait for J.G Snyder cut uh
yes uh that's gonna be a good time
Jersey Girl the Snyder Cup May 28th it's
my castle Cinemas also would you be open
to signing any of your Daredevil stuff
at the signing in July yeah we're having
a signing at Jane Sal and Bob's secret
stash because secret stash press my
comic imprint at uh Dark Horse which now
I'll be writing a lot more for I
can't write for the writer's Guild and
like that
um uh we're doing a signing it's sold
out already but we're going to add a
second day all the slots are for
Saturday sold out because two hard
covers are coming out masquerade one
through four hardcover and quick stops
one thing four hardcover coming out
um so uh Brian o'holleran's joining me
for the the signing on I think it's July
1st and then I think we're adding a July
2nd or the next day a Sunday signing
since all the slots sold out
um and he says will I sign DD stuff I'll
sign whatever you bring you know
I'm sure Mike zapsick will be like only
four things or whatever to but you
bring it I'll sign it you know how long
it takes me to sign a thing it's like
it's one of the easiest things I
do in my job uh also looking forward to
Bears driving later that day that's
going to be the move man July
1st bear is driving the clerk's cartoon
marathon it's my castlecinemas.com go
get your tickets right now kids
um Chris M for five bucks
come on Chris
what are we gonna do with five
bucks come on Kevin considered showing
prawns at the theater drive that
business up we have considered it uh
apparently uh the good folks in the town
fathers and mothers of Atlantic
Highlands uh New Jersey long time ago
because that movie theater has been you
know how old my movie theater is Mark
how
102 years old older than AMC can you
believe that uh does that break
feel good in a place like that too yes
they opened it as a garage years ago and
then in 1921
um it became the Atlantic theater just
recently at
um it wasn't I don't think it was at the
Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back screening
I think it was that oh when we did the
Guardians watch Along Watch with Kev
periodically I do that like for example
June 16th and 17th Friday and Saturday
when the flash comes out
I will be doing a watch with Kev at at
smog Castle Cinemas tickets haven't gone
on sale yet because they haven't put the
tickets for Flash up for sale yet
although it should be damned soon but
I'll let folks know by my social media
channels when that happens we did a
watch with Kev for the Guardians opening
night of guardians of galaxy the
Thursday night screening Thursday night
at smart Castle Cinemas we had 100
150 people there all of whom
paid five dollars more to watch the
movie with me and watch me do a q a for
a movie I had nothing to do with
whatsoever uh so somebody in that
audience brought a lobby card
from the Atlantic
theater from night the 19 I want to say
30s
um it had a Jolson movie listed and
somebody else I want to say Betty Davis
or something like that maybe maybe not
Betty Davis but it was amazing man the
guy had it framed and like that I
traded him a signed hockey jersey and
free tickets uh for it and we're gonna
be hanging it up in our lobby but that's
our theater is old man like we
were talking about can we get it
protected you know one of those so like
this is a Historic Landmark and
so we're looking into that now and
in any event as Chris M asked what about
Sean prawns in the town ordinance we
cannot show prawns
can't show any adult movies there
because believe me I thought for a
second I could make a nickel off people
doing a circle jerk in my movie theater
you better believe you better believe
I'd do it
um you know we can't get people to show
up for are you there God it's me
Margaret but maybe we could get him to
show up for are you there God let's jerk
off to this pornography together but
sadly that's not the case so no prawns
no prawns oh look at this I see a
49.99
for almost fifty dollar Super
Chat and people keep pointing out that
you know uh YouTube takes 30 of the
Super Chat I'm like I get it I mean
I didn't I didn't think we were getting
all of this I mean they're getting
nothing for nothing in this life
and YouTube Built This thing so I'm sure
they take their cut man
um in any event who that Disney said Hey
Kevin and Mark hope the writers get what
they deserve soon this is Brian Plato
from Nola oh Brian he's in he was
in uh James sound Bob reboot with us he
started as like a background extra in
that movie he went on to Bill and Ted
face the music got to work on that and
like that now he's like he went
from a background guy to a what's not
background foreground guy like he's
suddenly he's in movies and anyway
yeah I met him at the some of the The
Overlook Film Festival he swung through
he was there the Overlook he was there
he came to see Splinter Mark showed his
movie Splinter there how was that when
you did it that was awesome so much fun
it's also New Orleans so hooray uh he
asked did you ever get to read the tune
that I wrote hemp night rise of the
voodoo zombie blunt man it's the one
Mark and I talked about talked about for
Splinter Kickstarter yeah not gotten to
read it Mark did you get to read it I
did read it because he uh one of the the
tiers of backers for the the Splinter
Kickstarter was that somebody would send
me up to 100 pages of whatever and I'd
read it and we'd talk about it for about
an hour and
um I remember it being like
if Kevin loves this it's awesome I don't
know if anybody would or could love it
as much as Kevin would or could love it
because it is very much a love letter to
to blunt man
um speaking of a love letter to
blunderman hmm
you know what I can't speak about it so
let's just leave it there
do you want to see my dick nobody wants
to see your dick
well I can't show you anywhere uh we
answered Josh mundhal's question
um didn't we we did yeah you stay
inspired it seems the last couple of
strikes but yeah you answered that you
answered Jeremiah Maxwell's 99 question
right
um which wasn't a question you just said
can't wait for the screws for the crew
for the screws for the cruise on that
cruise lots of square miles Maxwell
um no more Super chat questions so we
could just go to the regular chat
questions of fungal I ask Kevin is that
lavender it is this is lavender spray
man I love it it keeps me calm it smells
so good uh as I said earlier
Tuesday is 16 weeks for me weed free I
guess technically what is that four
months I should stop doing weeks but it
sounds so much more impressive
but it's been about four months since I
smoked weed man now to be fair prior to
that I'd been smoking weed straight for
since 2008 15 years almost I almost
reached my 15-year anniversary of
smoking weed I started smoking
um well first I spoke with Seth Rogen on
this the rap day of Jane's of not James
uh Zach and Mary make a porno but then I
didn't smoke again until July
so yeah I guess I'm way way months away
from hitting the official 15-year
anniversary but if you go from calendar
year to calendar year I smoked weed for
15 years bucking straight 10 of those
years the last 10 was like
to a dissociative bucket of mountains I
talked about that in my mental health
video we could watch right here on
YouTube trauma is trauma it's called a
lot of people like that's the best movie
ever made and I that traumatized
me
further traumatizing me I might have to
go into the booby hatchback
because I'm crazy
um but a lot of people have been uh
giving me very nice uh notices about
that right here in chat I've been off
social media man when I put that thing
up I was like I'm not going back to
social media I saw that as my Cortez
moment where I was like I could burn my
ships I'm in the new world I could burn
my ships to motivate my men
so I haven't been with social
media that much I put up a lot of
notices about what's playing at smodcast
Castle but I don't read the comments
anymore this is the first time I've been
reading comments since uh since
I jumped but we have to kind of do that
for this show I I do not miss Twitter
um I'm I'm I'm about 100 I'm like 99 off
Twitter
um I will look at it if somebody sends
me a link to a thing to watch or if I
get some weird email about somebody
sending me a DM but otherwise
don't need it don't want it
um Melanie dawn said you didn't read my
super chat it's I don't see it anywhere
Melanie Dawn
um
for your traumas trauma video I'm so
happy you are have pushed through I can
totally relate to your story much love
to you was that Melanie Dawn that was
Melanie Dawn well thank you Melanie that
means the absolute world man I've met
people in the real world who've given me
props on on that video which is very
sweet apparently it hit a bunch of
people in the right in the right place
and that's what it was meant for when I
was uh in Sierra Tucson uh in the mental
health facility after about two weeks I
was like Jesus man like I'm learning I'm
age 52 and I didn't know half of this
I didn't know any of this to
be honest with you trauma to me was just
like a ward in the hospital so I was
like man like I'm lucky enough I got the
kind of health care or let's be honest
Insurance didn't pay for it so I was
able to pay for it myself but I got the
kind of Health Care that like other
people can't even afford or dream about
getting and with that information I was
like I'm not going to sit on this
information I want to disseminate it
instead so I knew back then when I was
in inside that I was going to shoot a
video and put it up and stuff for a
bunch of people because I remember
talking about my heart attack after the
heart attack and
for the next five years people were like
my God you talked about your heart
attack on Colbert I was like he's not
much older than me and I went in and
had my heart checked and I had
like 90 occlusion you saved my life I
was like no I'm pretty sure a doctor
saved your life but it just proves that
a little information will go a long way
so I right then and there when I was
inside I was like you know I'm learning
very useful I can't wait to get out
and share it with people and uh so far
so good uh reaction's been very very
positive I'm sure there have been people
who are like you crazy boy roll
around in your money and cry
your crazy tears or whatever the
but that hasn't reached my ears so
although that one guy called me
irrelevant
I just I have in my head I wish I could
remember the name of the specific Bugs
Bunny cartoon
and then every now and again he just
when I was in Sierra Tucson I was
literally always doing like my name is
Elmer J Fudd millionaire
um all right what else can we do man or
are we getting out of here shouldn't we
talk a little have you seen Guardians
yet I have not seen Guardians yet I'm
going Friday morning I'm gonna I'm gonna
take my son who uh who comes home from
college tomorrow how awesome is that so
I go and get him from college then we go
Friday morning to go see Guardians
um I have no Sons so I watched Guardians
don't remind me I have no son it's very
traumatizing no I actually never wanted
a son I was so happy when we were having
a daughter and did have a daughter uh
Harley because I was like what am I
gonna do with another man in
this world man
um but having a having a daughter has
been everything
um uh she I dig her so much she just
went to a premiere last night Charlie
day is that from uh
he's friends with Austin they were in
that movie
um Austin Zager Harley's boyfriend who
played blockchain Coltrane in uh clerks
three Charlie day is a movie I think
it's called Fool's Paradise
um somebody in chat will tell me if I'm
wrong anyway they had a Premiere last
night at the Chinese right down the
street and um
which would call it uh the kid they sent
me pictures man my kid looked
Dynamite Man she was all dressed
up to the nine so was Austin but like I
thought the kid looked wonderful
um and I text her I was like my God
well well done Heavens
um but that movie
um I asked her I was like how was it and
um and uh Harley of course loved it and
she was a costume so funny
uh but what else is she gonna say for
having sex
um head notes
I think how was it she's gone I got some
notes
um Scott K asks coming in later is Kev
okay he looks red that's because I
didn't put on any native
sunscreen kids if only I had
heeded my own advice as I go hike Runyon
and put on some native sunscreen I
wouldn't look so goddamn red native
sunscreen go to nativedeo.com Fatman
make your order right now uh Jonah rod
and adrenal right the second in chat
mentioned that that Bugs Bunny short is
hair devil air devil which one where
he's like yeah that one uh Jose
interesting people Jose monster asked
would you write for in Super Chat not
just chat but Super Chat uh for 9.99 he
said would you write a new book about
your experience it will help so many
people uh yes it's funny you should
mention that Jose
something I've been thinking about I've
been toying with the idea of writing
another book you know years ago I wrote
tough which is available from
penguin random house I guess still
um and and after the heart attack I was
like I should write a book about the
heart attack
um but you know my brain my heart broke
five years ago my brain broke
you know this year
feel like maybe I should write a
book and being that there's a writer
strike that don't count right that can't
stop me from writing a book can they
mark
no I don't believe so yeah I don't think
the writing books is part of the wga I
will maybe I'll use this time the strike
time to
put some thoughts together on becoming
an old man and how things break every
five years my heart broke five years ago
my brain broke five years later what
will break next kids my dick my
who knows I'll be writing so much if it
ain't broke fix it by Kevin Smith oh my
God there's the title right there I was
gonna go with kevolution but
that's way better
um
uh bibli says a journey on
self-discovery sounds difficult to write
yeah
I don't know I guess I don't know I mean
I hate to say this but like I I love
writing so much nothing's ever really
difficult to write do you ever get
writer's block Mark I get that I asked
that a lot and I'm like I don't get
writer's block as much as I get writer's
lays periodically I would rather watch a
thing than create a thing but what
happens is while I watch a thing I get
like jealous when I'm like why are they
writing a thing and I'm not I can do
that and then I go back to writing a
thing it kind of prompts me to
to actually go to work you yeah you know
I've never gotten writer's block and I
think some of that is because
the first half of my career was trying
to break in
you know and so the there was always
energy beyond that and then once I did
break in it was oh and I have to
pay rent
like you know my joke was always I don't
have writer's block I have bills
which means like I have to write like
there's just no there's no option to not
write
um you know and so I I think that that I
there are so there are problems that
need solving and stuff that I work on
it is never like I I've never sat down
to write and never been able to do it
but it's always huh okay well that's
gonna be tricky or I got to figure this
out or whatever it'll solve itself I'll
take a shower I'll go for a walk I'll go
for a drive and while I'm doing it while
my brain is busy doing other the
problems get solved in the background so
I got like a program that's always
running but but I've never I've never
had what people characteristically call
writer's block
yeah I don't get it either I'm never
like what can I I can't get through this
I mean let's be honest most of the
I write is very
uncomplicated anyway and stuff it's not
like I'm writing stranger things
or something like that I mean you saw
yoga hosers I should have been writer's
blocked for that movie
instead I had writer's diarrhea
Victor Lopez chat gave us 50 American
dollars what does Victor want Victor
says sober for one year now during my
time got to meet you last year in St
Louis the best sober experience I've had
at Fan Expo St Louis my next trip will
be to the stash in New Jersey for my
two-year goal congratulations Victor oh
my Lord thanks for everything you guys
create that means the world if you're
going to come to the stash uh make sure
there's something cool happening at
Smock Castle Cinemas man so you could do
that as well double fist it man go to
the stash go to spawn Castle Cinemas
just
um oh we got a 20 one in here from Queen
cam you mean green cam are you Mark go
ahead hey Mark fellow chocolate geek uh
love Splinter so proud of you Hey Kevin
the trauma video was so brave and
profound so proud of you too happy you
are loving you as much as we do will
there be less fat man beyond
um I don't think so yeah probably more
fat man beyond if anything yeah I mean
we really had an issue though lately
because we wanted to hit
you know
um the 400th show live yeah so
we kept putting it off any show we would
have done would have been 400 but we
found a way around that kid so you're
watching show
399.1 right now yep we got nine more of
this yes
but yeah we were supposed to do one
yesterday on the ninth
um but I I had to cancel because I had a
death in the family
um that both required me to to have to
pull out of that as well as the northern
fan con up in up in Prince George which
I I always love attending I always have
the best time there but this weekend was
not to be
um and so we're trying to coordinate our
schedules so that we will both be in La
at the same time and it's not like a
Friday night with a Cantina it's like we
have no time for you we don't we don't
serve you're kind here
well yeah droids
um uh Graham bliley asked a pretty
decent question goes can you change the
name of the show to something less self
self-deprecating and more accurate glad
men Beyond maybe a few people talk about
that you know part of my uh
self-loathing uh was you know
calling myself fat before somebody else
did and whatnot hence uh Fat Man on
Batman which then became fat man beyond
um it's a it's a decent question I I
don't you know we built a brand and it
feels like
if we change the name of the show
would people know we were I guess it
really doesn't matter does it it doesn't
matter but I thought you know when we
talked about the change from fat men on
Batman to fat man beyond it was
something I always liked about the
beyond the idea is we've gone beyond
feminine that we've we're transitioning
from one thing into something else weird
there it's always a journey Life is a
Highway and we're gonna ride it all
night long all night long just like that
Canadian guy said yeah and also one of
us is still fat so I don't think we're
not being uh particularly true let me
tell you both of us are still fat if I
stand up take my shirt off you'll be
like oh keep calling it fat man beyond I
I assure you just because one loses
weight don't mean that excess
skin goes away and like that I was
driving uh into Manhattan last week I
went up into the city while I was back
in Jersey uh twice on Wednesday and
Thursday and as you take the Lincoln
Tunnel in there's this giant billboard
that like have excess fat you know call
this number for surgery and and um
it's an image of somebody but their head
is cut off but you could see like their
their body and so you could see like the
excess skin the flab if you will and
when I was looking at the billboard I
was like I totally could have posed for
that and if they gave me money I put my
face on it too like I wouldn't
hide that I'd be like hey kids it's
me Kev Smith
um because I can't write for a living
anymore so I might as well make money
that way a before model
you know or an after model whatever
on a billboard for that sort of thing
um
Captain Robert April says that makes you
flap man not fat man
well done my friend raise the flaps
hardcore cutesy curtsy sorry uh says uh
thank you in Super Chat five American
dollar says thank you for your
inspiration saw you in San Francisco and
offered to review your bathing suit area
told you about a script you inspired
working on it I feel like a writer Now's
the Time to write
you know whether you're a member of the
wga or not I mean are you allowed here's
a question mark yeah actually this is a
Special Edition version of fat man
Beyond in which we're talking mostly
about the writer's Guild strike and Mark
if you coming in late Mark has been
educating all of us on on the strike
um
like you can't write for a studio right
now but can you write for yourself
absolutely 100 like if if I wanted to
ride a pilot or a movie which I am gonna
do if this strike goes on for long
enough
um it still belongs to me I haven't been
engaged to do it by any but I've been
sent a contract nobody's offering me
money if I'm writing for myself they can
never stop you from writing for yourself
so you're not a scab if you if you write
a script that you haven't sold yet
correct like and the minute the strike
is over I can then take that script and
try and sell it with no adverse effect
by The Guild nobody doesn't look at you
funny nobody's gonna take anything away
from you and there's very little they
can actually take away from you for
scabbing other than you know moral High
ground and your soul
remember early in the show when I was
telling kids Now's the Time to go make a
an independent movie and and
somebody was like are you
advocating
uh being a scab Like This falls under
the same heading if you're not
selling it
yeah
that's Gavin it's just for you
we be scabbing hey yeah
um somebody who was it oh waste wasatron
2000 says maybe just change the fat man
beyond logo from a cape to kev's gut
flaps that you're both floating in
like you're some human flying squirrel
yes yes oh my God you're absolutely
right if I ever have to jump from a tall
building I'd just be like
I knew that would come in handy you
know what I did yesterday is um
I went and did uh uh two bears one pod
heard Chrysler normally he does it with
Tom seguro and I was on
Tom segura's uh your mom's house podcast
which he normally does with Christine
prashinski but she wasn't there the dad
did the show and Tom wasn't there
yesterday when I did a show with Bert
and had such a great time I
don't know when he puts it up and stuff
but my God it was it was it was a good
time he's a legit funny guy and he he's
uh one of those people that like when he
talks about a movie he never does the
title
he describes it by what the movie's
about and he was just like
um he goes uh Ben and Mac get wings and
I was like dogma and he goes yeah that
movie
[Laughter]
[Music]
I walk the picket line with the other
day uh Brett Goldstein are you
serious Roy Kent was there he's here
there and everything bro I can't he's
here he's there he's every where
Roy Ken I met him before he was where I
can he did does a podcast or did I don't
know if he does anymore uh when I was
over in the UK for Jay and Samba reboot
back in 2019 before the world
shut down
um I was on his podcast and I like I
Remember Loving that podcast because it
was a cool concept films to be buried
with yes films to be buried with and he
um and we had a good ass time in
but he at that point he wasn't there was
no Ted lasso I don't think he'd even
been on it like I don't think they'd
even shot it and so then when I saw Ted
lasso I was like I love that guy
that plays Roy Kent I think I was
talking about it on this show and
somebody was like you met him and I was
like no I didn't I'd remember that like
you were on his podcast and I was on his
podcast did you get to talk to him I did
a little bit because um I was walking
with Yvette Nicole Brown who's a friend
and she oh my God kids put on your hard
hats because Mark Bernard is dropping
names left reigning names
um but I was walking with her and she
has been like the moderator of every Ted
lasso event in La like somehow she got
in like deep with those guys and so
Yvette introduced me to Brett and so we
just walked for bit so how do you know
it it's like oh are you married
uh no not married to a vet I'm not that
lucky
um and then he like disappeared off
because sudakis was also walking the
line and Brennan hunt coach beard was
walking this was a Warner Brothers I
think last week
um
but it has been like if if you wanted to
like celebrity site like come walk in
line you don't have to be in the guild
you have to be in any Guild to come and
walk a picket line they will gladly
welcome their support and like what did
I see today I saw Larry Wilmore I saw
Paula Patton
um Leland orser was out at Paramount
today
um
yeah yeah yeah no it's been good it's a
real scene on those picket lines you
know for the first couple weeks Man Out
Come the shiny people to lend their
support Andy Samberg was walking the
Paramount line today Seth Myers I saw
was walking the picket lines in New York
meeting with Tina Fey and I think um
Pete Davidson was delivering pizza to
folk Pizza when are we uh me and I I'm
I'm uh headed back to see my mom uh this
week uh on on I leave on Friday but I
come back to Los Angeles
on um I think it's Wednesday or
something so are we gonna walk the
picket line a week from tomorrow
Thursday we absolutely can you know
whenever you want like I'm not I'm not
every day anymore just because it's I'm
old and it's a lot
um but I'm trying like Monday Wednesday
Friday you know Monday Tuesday Thursday
whatever that's gonna work out so let me
know whenever you want man we can we can
we can be in town we can be on this side
of the hill we can go up to Universal we
can go up to one where do you want to
pick it where do you what are you
looking for where can one pick it where
should we pick it where have you picked
it so far I've been at Universal I've
been to CBS in the valley CBS Radford a
lot
um that's where we shot Jay and Silent
Bob Strike Back see Miss Radford was
cool that's where they make a lot of
sitcoms right yeah a lot of sitcoms some
like one hour like network type of shows
um I did Warner Brothers and Disney and
then today was Paramount and I haven't
done Netflix or Amazon or Sony or Fox
yet on this side of the Hill
you're gonna hit them all dude I mean
I'm it's it's the world tour at this
point
um and especially when it gets too hot
in The Valleys when I come down it's
like hey Fox tell me what it's like over
here where's 20 degrees cooler in the
valley kids it gets very very
hot frying pan of L.A it bakes like
crazy man uh somebody who said this was
cute uh we were talking about Pete
Davidson delivering pizza John Elrod too
said Pizza Davidson
nice
nice nice nice your little dad
joke right there um George Dwight DeWitt
asked uh Mark is there a ton of
Paparazzi at the lines taking photos of
all the people there would think they'd
be looking for celebs helping out or
walking
um there's not a ton of Paparazzi
honestly
um there's a decent amount of news
coverage you know there's a lot of like
I see AP photographers I see like LA
Times photographers and and that sort of
thing but I have yet to capture like you
know the paparazzi he's like Jason Jason
look over here Jason Jason
thank you Jason you know I haven't seen
that red carpety feel yet
Tom Smash Super chatted us British money
I got pounds under that Tom uh and he
said keep doing show guys just want to
say thank you oh my God you're more than
welcome Tom you didn't have to pay us
four dollars and 20 pounds or whatever
however you say that
pounds 20 quid I don't know four pounds
20. four pounds 20.
um when he pee nerd tropolis says can we
moderate your panel at the Dallas Fan
Expo I don't really have moderators I
generally kind of do that myself
I've never done a Fan Expo I hear
they're lovely I've been to many me and
Jay uh did like think about
10 or 12 over the course of the last
year I think the Dallas one is one of
our last not ever but for the fan Expos
I think we were we were contracted to do
like 15 or something like that but
they're they're lovely
absolutely lovely it's always great when
you get to like
meat cats that are like you know
hey man all of your
um kids we would love to do this all
night long uh but really we just uh
gathered to kind of talk about
the strike with thank uh the wonderful
Mark Bernardin who came up with the idea
of let's educate people about this this
year's strike and hopefully people walk
away
a little bit uneducated yeah this this
is the news this week this is the news
for the next couple of weeks
um so it felt it felt about right felt
like this was a good time with a little
bit of perspective a little bit of
distance but it's an evolving situation
and so when when there's new to
report when there's a break in the ice
and and feelings begin to thaw and
people are back at the negotiating table
will come back and tug strike but
for now this felt like a good idea
um tune in next time for episode
499.2 kids
we'll do it maybe uh early next week
after Marcus scene Guardians so we can
yeah we'll do a Guardians Deep dive talk
about it and now that you know the
strikes going on and we don't have to
write for people perhaps the
show will be a lot more consistent
you know and now we have some time maybe
we'll get back into some some commentary
tracks it's true man maybe we do it live
I mean I guess you could technically do
it live we if we both played them at the
same time I mean we could be in the same
place and do it of course but
you could be where you are I could be
where I am and we could just sync up and
then do it live yeah just tell
everybody just watch along now generally
what I like to do before we do those
Batman watch-alongs is I watch it the
night before and write down a bunch of
things if I have ready to go so
we're never like you know in
silence but would that be considered
writing
would that be scab work right there
that's you need to look in your own soul
my own scabby Soul yeah
uh kids if you enjoyed uh fat man beyond
if you've ever enjoyed fat man beyond
you have uh the guy over there to thank
for give it up for the great Mark
Bernard
um you also have uh will Wilkins to
thank dilfman he makes sure that you we
get to you and don't forget
Banff man get your ass in here
bamping there he is now he's back dance
man's here man how's that how at
the bar real quick before we go I know
Mark's got out of here but how was uh
May the 4th at Scotty the busiest day
we've ever had but also one of the
smoothest we've ever had
everybody is just firing on all
cylinders it was awesome opened at 10 am
had at 10 A.M by about four o'clock in
the afternoon we had a two hour line to
get in until 12 30 at night
and at 10 AM where people drinking
alcohol
they were
Vegas hours wow
um well I mean celebrating Star Wars
what the
um so was it your biggest Day Ever it's
coming villainy it was it was it beat
last year by about 15 percent
wow um humongous and chat said no Mohawk
what's happening it is it's just
not spiked
it's just laying down
and that's where all the kids we're all
gonna lay the down
it's been a busy week striking and doing
fat man beyond about the strike and
stuff uh come back next week my friends
where we'll do uh uh fat man beyond
499.2 we're just gonna bring this out
until we could do I mean 3.99
399.2 until we can get together and do
it live which will probably be
I mean what if it was next week when
we'd walk the picket lines on Thursday
I don't know I don't know if we can do
Thursday at the so that's right JC can
we
Bam Bam
what what nights are good for you for
fat man Monday Tuesday Sunday afternoon
Sunday mark
Sunday the 21st
is that what would it would be
yeah are you around
I will be here yeah because I do
Hollywood Babylon kids Hollywood Babylon
at Flappers Comedy Club May 20th
Saturday night get your tickets right
now at csmod.com a free ad right there
um so yeah I'll be in town for that so
the 21st we could do an afternoon show
at the Cantina if we want to all agree
yes
400. it could be
that's an easy hook to sell with man you
know it's like show 400 people who
aren't going to want to miss that and
also like the first Live LA show in like
a year no kidding man look for
those tickets at ceasemob.com kids
that's where it is everybody uh
for fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith and
I'm Mark Bernardin tune in next time
it'll probably be early next week same
bath time same uh oh wait a second
orbius just came in with 50 bucks at the
Super Chat money on the table
what you want more of yourself yes we
can because Mr Smith of a 45 year old
man who weighs 390 pounds in your recent
video could have been made by me with a
few details flipped around here and
there I want you to know that I am
grateful for your candor and your
example thank you uh orbias orobius
thank you for that
um for heaven's sakes that means the
absolute world uh if people are like
what is he talking about uh trauma is
trauma is the video right here on my
channel kids watch that I'm not crazy
and I talk about it anyway back to the
sign off next I'm saying it's
about time same fat channels podcast.com
or youtube.com Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss
everybody
go strike
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]